♪♪
>>> EVEN AMID THE DEVASTATING
TRAGEDY IN UVALD THE TOP GUN
LOBBY IN THE UNITED STATES, THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION,
PUSHED AHEAD WITH ITS ANNUAL
CONVENTION HELD IN HOUSTON, JUST
A FEW HUNDRED MILES AWAY FROM
HERE.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
CANCELLED HIS IN-PERSON
APPEARANCE AND INSTEAD HIS
REMARKS WERE PRERECORDED FOR THE
EVENT.
>> YEAH.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
AND OTHER GOP LEADERS THAT DID
ATTEND REJECTED EFFORTS TO
OVERHAUL GUN LAWS.
ACTUALLY MOCKING DEMOCRATS ALONG
WITH ACTIVISTS WHO ARE CALLING
FOR CHANGE.
HERE IS CNN'S RYAN YOUNG WHO IS
IN HOUSTON WITH MORE.
>> Reporter: YEAH, BORIS AND
CHRISTI, THE EMOTIONS ARE
RUNNING HIGH OUTSIDE THE
CONVENTION CENTER.
MORE THAN 1,000 PEOPLE SHOWED UP
FOR A RALLY TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT FOR BANNING ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
YOU CAN FEEL THE EMOTIONS FROM
THOSE FOLKS WHO SAY NOTHING IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
♪♪
♪ PROUD TO BE AN AMERICAN ♪
>> Reporter: FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP RALLYING WITH THE
NATIONAL RIVAL ASSOCIATION AS IT
HOLDS ITS ANNUAL MEETING AFTER
19 CHILDREN AND 2 ADULTS WERE
MASSACRED IN UVALDE.
>> THE EXISTENCE OF EVIL IN OUR
WORLD NOT TO BAN LAW ASIDING
CITIZENS CAN PROTECT A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THE EXISTENCE OF EVIL IS ONE OF
THE BEST REASONS TO ARM
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
>> Reporter: INSTEAD OF NEW GUN
LAWS, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
CALLING FOR MORE FOCUS ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND SCHOOL SECURITY.
>> WHAT WE NEED NOW IS A TOP TO
BOTTOM SECURITY OVERHAUL AT
SCHOOLS ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: THOSE ARGUMENTS
ECHOED BY OTHERS WHO ADDRESSED
THE NRA'S ANNUAL CONVENTION IN
HOUSTON, INCLUDING TEXAS SENATOR
TED CRUZ.
>> WE MUST NOT REACT TO EVIL AND
TRAGEDY BY ABANDONING THE
CONSTITUTION OR INFRINGING ON
THE RIGHTS OF OUR LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
>> Reporter: THE NRA CONDEMNED
THE UVALDE SHOOTING BUT DECIDED
TO PRESS AHEAD WITH ITS
GATHERING.
THOUGH SEVERAL MUSICAL
PERFORMERS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
CANCELLED APPEARANCES IN THE
WAKE OF TUESDAY'S SHOOTING.
>> NRA-
>> GO AWAY.
>> NRA.
>> GO AWAY!
>> Reporter: ACROSS THE STREET A
CROWD OF PROTESTERS GATHERED
OUTSIDE THE CONVENTION CENTER.
>> I'M LOOKING AT YOU, THE NRA
TODAY.
I DON'T WANT ANY MORE OF MY
PEERS TO DIE IN A SCHOOL.
>> Reporter: OUTRAGE OVER THE
HIGH PROFILE REPUBLICAN SPEAKERS
THE MEETING ATTRACTED.
>> SHAME ON YOU.
SHAME ON YOU.
>> Reporter: FORMER TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN BETO O'ROURKE, THE
STATE'S DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR
GOVERNOR, JOINED THOSE OUTSIDE
THE VENUE CALLING FOR ACTION.
>> THE TIME FOR US TO STOPPED
UVALDE WAS RIGHT AFTER SANDY
HOOK.
IF YOU HAVE DONE ANYTHING GOOD,
IT IS THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
BROUGHT US HERE TOGETHER AND
THAT WE ARE COMMITTING OURSELVES
TO ACT.
>> Reporter: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT WAS INITIALLY SCHEDULED
TO APPEAR IN PERSON BUT SENT A
VIDEO MESSAGE INSTEAD.
>> THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF LAWS
ON THE BOOKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT LIMIT THE OWNING OR USING
OF FIREARMS.
LAWS THAT HAVE NOT STOPPED
MADMEN FROM CARRYING OUT EVIL
ACTS ON INNOCENT PEOPLE AND
PEACEFUL COMMUNITIES.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE SIGNS
THAT PROTESTERS LEFT BEHIND.
LOOK, THEY'RE TIRED OF ALL THE
TALK AND BACK AND FORTH.
THEY SAID THEY WANT TO HEAR MORE
CONCRETE ANSWERS FOR HOW THINGS
CAN CHANGE, BUT THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED AS OF YET.
AND THOSE EMOTIONS KEPT RUNNING
HIGH AS THE NIGHT WENT ON.
BORIS AND CHRISTI?
>> RYAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOHN
CORNYN, WHO IS LEADING
REPUBLICANS IN BIPARTISAN TALKS
WITH DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS TO
FIND A MIDDLE GROUND ON GUN
REFORM LEGISLATION SAID THURSDAY
THAT DISCUSSIONS AMONG THE GROUP
WERE, QUOTE, JUST GETTING
STARTED AND DEMOCRATIC SENATOR
JOE MANCHIN, WHO WAS IN ON THAT
MEETING, SAID SO FAR IT'S BEEN,
QUOTE, VERY ENCOURAGING.
CNN'S DANIELA DIAZ ON CAPITOL
HILL THIS MORNING.
ARE YOU GETTING A SENSE FROM
SENATOR MANCHIN THAT SOMETHING
IS DIFFERENT THIS TIME AROUND?
>> Reporter: HE SAID IT HIMSELF
WHEN HE TALKED TO REPORTERS
AFTER MEETING WITH THIS
BIPARTISAN GROUP ON THURSDAY.
HE SAID, OF COURSE, YOU JUST
QUOTED HIM.
HE CALLED IT VERY ENCOURAGING.
BUT HE COMPARED TO TALKS AFTER
SANDY HOOK SHOOTING, ALSO VERY
HORRIFIC.
HE SAID, QUOTE, I WAS HERE IN
2013 AFTER THE SANDY HOOK
SHOOTING AND GETTING PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE BACK THEN UNTIL PAT
TOOMEY STEPPED FORWARD WASN'T
ANYONE JUMPING FORWARD.
HE'S REALLY IMPLYING THAT
REPUBLICANS WEREN'T EAGER TO
START DISCUSSIONS WITH DEMOCRATS
ON SOME SORT OF GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION OR SOME SORT OF
LEGISLATION THAT COULD HELP
COMBAT ANY FUTURE, HORRIFIC
SHOOTINGS.
A PATTERN IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
WE'VE SEEN AGAIN AND AGAIN.
OF COURSE, THIS COMES AFTER
SENATE MINORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL, THE TOP REPUBLICAN IN
THE SENATE GAVE HIS BLESSING TO
SENATOR JOHN CORNYN, THE SENIOR
SENATOR FROM TEXAS TO START
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH
DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS OF COURSE BEING VERY
EAGER TO PASS SOME SORT OF BILL
IN THE SENATE, BUT THEY NEED AT
LEAST TEN REPUBLICANS TO SIGN ON
TO ANY LEGISLATION TO BREAK THAT
60-VOTE THRESHOLD FOR THE
FILIBUSTER.
OTHER THAN THAT, IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE TEN REPUBLICANS TO SIGN
ON WITH EVERY DEMOCRAT SIGNING
ON, NO BILL CAN PASS.
NOW, I DO WANT TO REFERENCE THAT
THERE IS SUCH A CONTRAST BETWEEN
WHAT SENATOR JOHN CORNYN IS
DOING, OF COURSE, PARTICIPATING
IN THIS BIPARTISAN DISCUSSION ON
SOME SORT OF GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION VERSUS WHAT SENATOR
TED CRUZ, THE OTHER SENATOR FROM
TEXAS, IS DOING.
TEXAS, OF COURSE, BEING WHERE
THAT HORRIFIC SHOOTING TOOK
PLACE AT THAT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT SENATOR
TED CRUZ SAID WAS TO BLAME ABOUT
THIS SHOOTING, NOT FAULTING GUNS
BUT EVERYTHING BUT.
>> ULTIMATELY, AS WE ALL KNOW,
WHAT STOPS ARMED BAD GUYS IS
ARMED GOOD GUYS.
WE MUST NOT REACT TO EVIL AND
TRAGEDY BY ABANDONING THE
CONSTITUTION OR INFRINGING ON
THE RIGHTS OF OUR LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
>> Reporter: CHRISTI, I REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS SHOWS
THERE'S STILL SUCH A DIVIDE
WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ON
HOW TO HANDLE GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION WITH, YOU KNOW,
SENATOR TED CRUZ AND SENATOR
JOHN CORNYN REALLY SHOWING THAT
DIVIDE WITH CORNEN, OF COURSE,
PARTICIPATING IN THE BIPARTISAN
TALKS AND SENATOR TED CRUZ STILL
SAYING THAT GUN LEGISLATION DOES
NOT NEED TO HAPPEN, THAT
EVERYTHING BUT IS THE REASON TO
BLAME FOR THE SHOOTING.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A RE